Quindi abbiamo fatto questa metta, questa gentilezza amorevole verso gli altri, ma quello che a lui sembra che manchi è un po' un amore verso il corpo, questo potere di guarigione.
Quindi il primo esercizio è solo augurare benevolenza verso il nostro corpo.
Quindi usiamo una forma di benedizione, che tu sia libero dalla malattia, che tu sia sano, che tu sia forte.
In questa maniera iniziamo a direttare questa benedizione verso la parte fisica della nostra natura.
Quindi cominciamo a direzionare questa benevolenza verso la natura fisica del nostro essere.
Qui utilizziamo una forma di buddismo tibetano che suppone che ci sia una forma di energia nell'universo che ci aiuta
nella tradizione si chiama il Buddha della medicina e vi chiederò di visualizzare, di immaginare una luce che scende su di voi dall'alto questo si trasforma poi in una palla che ha la consistenza di un fluido dorato
Quindi potrebbe avere il colore che voi immaginate che sia un colore di guarigione.
E lo facciamo lentamente girare giù a spirale lungo il corpo.
Poi condividiamo questa energia tra di noi.
E poi possiamo dare questa energia a una persona che ha bisogno di aiuto fisicamente.
E poi alla fine lo offriamo a tutti gli esseri in tutte le direzioni.
Quindi cominciamo con delle contemplazioni sul corpo.
in modo da avere una corretta relazione con il corpo.
Quindi la prima è per tradurre la nostra idea di possedere il corpo.
E prendo un esercizio dal Buddha stesso, che si tratta di guardare la natura disgustante del corpo.
Quindi prendo un esercizio che è la Buddha stessa che è osservare la natura disgustosa del corpo.
E lo spiegherò man mano che vado avanti.
Poi facciamo l'esercizio che abbiamo fatto tutte queste sere in cui si lascia andare il corpo come me o mio.
E poi facciamo
Poi contempliamo la preziosità del corpo.
E poi facciamo questo esercizio di buona gioia.
Come si dice New Age?
New Age, ecco, New Age.
Quindi, perché è New Age, dobbiamo, ovviamente, sedere in un circolo.
Se possiamo formare un circolo qui.
se non fanno anche più stretto
Insomma per questa occasione bruceremo un po' l'incenso.
è la musica in un age un po' di più un po' di più un po' di più
relaxatevi mettetevi in una posizione piacevole e meditativa e se vi sentite scomodi durante questo esercizio sentitevi liberi di cambiare la postura se lo fate silenziosamente non vi stupano e voi